i'm kat timf i'm bill hemmer i'm harris
faulkner and this is the fox news
rundown
[Music]
thursday march 31st 2022 i'm john
saucier one of the things i love about
fox news is that we have news resources
everywhere and wherever the news is we
have someone to send there when the news
is a war that someone is trey yingst
trey was able to join me in studio today
in new york after having spent the last
few weeks in ukraine understanding the
long-term impact on ukrainian civilians
and people who are trying to get out of
the way will be significant in our
coverage and i think we will try to
follow the lives of these people that
we've talked to and that we've met in
order to tell their story in a
comprehensive way this is the fox news
rundown war on ukraine
[Music]
we're speaking today with fox's trey
yinks who is fresh back from the ukraine
tray last time i talked to you you were
somewhere in kiev the capital city and i
remember hearing a shell going off
outside of your window now you're here
in new york the only thing happening
outside the window is people blowing
horns cabs yelling all this stuff what a
crazy difference just for you as far as
being in ukraine and now you're back
here in the united states what is that
like how are you feeling yeah it's a
juxtaposition you have
basically
a city and a country that is now
consumed by war so the sounds that you
hear in kiev while we're covering this
conflict
are consistent explosions in the
distance incoming and even outgoing
artillery you hear air strikes you hear
sirens wailing warning people to get
underground
gunfire and then you return to the
united states and its life is normal and
so i think it gives you some good
perspective about what life is like for
the people there but it also helps you
understand how out of place that is for
civilians who are caught in this
conflict
millions have fled around 4 million
according to the un but there are still
90 percent of the people
of ukraine in country and at risk amid
this conflict how do you process that
though how do you go from being in a war
zone and seeing just the worst parts of
humanity to all of a sudden being back
here in the united states where we're
kind of taking our freedom and our
everyday just thing for granted what's
that like
yeah i mean i have my own process of
reintegrating into society i think that
i'm used to it now covering war around
the world and each conflict is a little
bit different but i meditate i work out
i
talk to friends about the experience and
i reflect on what we've seen and who
we've talked to
and then i get back to work i mean i
love this job so it's very difficult for
me to
stay away from the story for too long
and i try to set limits on how much i'm
on social media and on twitter and
reading updates about the war
but i'm curious and even if i wasn't
working i'd probably be reading about
this stuff anyway so
it's kind of difficult to totally detach
from it but
i think
it is good to take a pause take a breath
reset and then
get ready to go again so that's my next
question do you plan to go back to
ukraine
yeah i think this war is going to go on
for a long time so eventually i'll end
up back there and continue my coverage
but i think for people who are fleeing
ukraine there are so many stories that
as an industry we have to follow and
continue and i think that there are
the immediate stories and the aftermath
of these strikes and the war
but understanding the long-term impact
on ukrainian civilians and people who
are trying to get out of the way will be
significant in our coverage and i think
we will try to follow the lives of these
people that we've talked to and that
we've met in order to tell their story
in a comprehensive way we're speaking
today with fox news foreign
correspondent trey yanks he's just back
from ukraine he spent weeks over there
this is not your first time in a war
zone trade though we had you in
afghanistan for the american withdrawal
there at the end which got really nasty
in that time i saw you riding around in
the back of trucks with taliban members
and my mind just blown and think wow we
have an american reporter over there
doing this stuff this time you're in a
full-on war zone with tanks guns
airstrikes everything else can you just
talk about the difference between those
two from what you had this summer to now
this winter
yeah i think you always have to remember
that you're dealing with people and so
even if they're members of the taliban
in kabul after the city's taken over
they have some reason why they're there
they have some incentive they feel and
experience emotions they have family
members
and although some of them have committed
heinous acts of violence they still have
a reason for why they do what they do
and when you understand that
and then also try to let them understand
that you are not there to threaten them
or to hurt them but simply to tell the
story of what's happening it can give
you some incredible access as a
journalist in the world to simply have a
reputation of telling the truth
and giving people a fair shot to speak
i think those
approaches are applicable in ukraine i
think the war zone though is quite
different we weren't really covering an
active conflict in afghanistan there
were threats and there were
concerns from groups like isis k and and
taliban factions like the haqqani
network but
it wasn't tanks in the streets it wasn't
daily air strikes that were targeting
positions all around us and i think
that's the major difference and
when you're in a war zone
there's a familiar tension that exists
24 7 and that tension
can't get in the way of you doing your
job but it also doesn't really allow the
mind to rest because you have to
constantly be prepared for something to
go wrong or for
a threat or an attack and
while the two war zones and conflict
areas are different based in part just
on the timeline of where they were
afghanistan the war was coming to an end
it was wrapping up ukraine we were there
the minute the war started we were
actually there before and in kiev as the
russians started to strike it
and so to be there during that time we
understood how significant that event
was
we're speaking today with fox news
foreign correspondent trey yinks on his
experience reporting on the war in
ukraine we've got more coming up next
okay i want to take it back to ukraine
now because you mentioned you were there
from the build up the beginning and now
you just recently left ukraine we've
heard all sorts of reports and we talk
ad nauseam all day long about what's
happening there we get reports from the
pentagon we get other reporters you were
there you were there for a lengthy
period of time and you weren't just
hanging out in the capital city you
moved around you saw a lot of things
what is your having just been their
assessment of not only how this war is
going but how the ukrainian people are
holding up in the face of this
superpower attacking them
they're certainly resilient and
those who can fight are pledging to do
so and they're calling on the
international community for even more
military support but
the reality is so many people's lives
have been upended and they don't know if
they'll ever return home so while there
is this storyline and you see it in the
international press and it is true of
the ukrainian resistance against this
invasion this violation of sovereignty
there is another story that's unfolding
at the same time and that is millions of
people
having to leave their homes
being internally displaced externally
displaced having to leave ukraine as a
whole
and these two things are going on at the
same time and so
there are more bloody days ahead
unfortunately for ukraine
there will be a continued effort to
reclaim territory if the russians do
pull back in their offensive
i don't think we're looking at a
scenario where the ukrainians just give
up
territory to the russians with nothing
in return
but it's
it's difficult to predict out what
that's going to look like because this
war could go on for a very long time we
may on day 36
as we speak
be looking at the very
beginning of
a long drawn-out conflict not only
between russia and ukraine but there is
that possibility of other players being
dragged in we're speaking today with
fox's trey yings foreign correspondent
he was in ukraine covering the war he's
been in many hot zones for us over the
years doing just that now trey you're
there for a good long while this time
part of your job is going out not only
getting the story but getting the
feeling and hearing from people who are
caught up in this i'm sure you could
already fill a book with the experiences
you've had but is there anything special
that you saw or people you talked to
over there then those experiences that
you would share with us
oftentimes when i'm asked this question
after a war i like to tell a really
uplifting story that stuck with me
the one interview that really stuck with
me was with a woman named evgenia
antonienko and she was fleeing the town
of erpine which was right where the
front line
started when russian forces started to
attack keeve
and there were
shells exploding around this area as she
was fleeing with her family
and
she described to me what really was the
worst day of her life and she
basically described
a nightmare as she tried to get out she
said to me it's like your life is broken
forever and you have no hope
and those words really stood out to me
because i think they're representative
for many ukrainians
and
you just looked into her eyes and she
described
trying to shield the eyes of her
daughter
as they fled european because there were
bodies in the streets
and when you
meet someone like that
and when you just sense their presence
around you and and you understand that
they are terrified but doing everything
they can to save their loved ones and
make sure their children get to safety
you empathize with them but you can
never truly understand their situation
we're there we're observing it we are
experiencing it alongside her we feel
the explosions
nearby we hear the blasts
but
to understand what it's like to leave
your entire life behind
it's something that we will try to
convey the story to the viewers but it's
something that i think about a lot
will we ever truly understand what that
feels like and i don't think we ever
will no it's hard to because it's one
thing to see it and to talk about it but
when it's your life it's a whole nother
thing and then really appreciate you
sharing that story because you can kind
of i guess feel that a little bit and
especially so that's just one example
but you're talking about millions of
people who've had to do just that fox's
trey yinks fresh from ukraine thanks for
being with us on your podcast foxy's
rundown the war on ukraine thanks for
having me
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes